[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones is back with its
last ever episode and the finale has a
hell of a lot to unpack from it this is
eight seasons of plot building and
storytelling coming to a head and
whether you hate it or love it we
finally know who has become the ruler of
the Seven Kingdoms throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the final episode
as well as what it's ending means this
is full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the finale and don't want anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for click in
this video I hope you enjoy it now sit
back relax and let's get into my Game of
Thrones finale breakdown we'll start
with a quick recap just to get everyone
up to speed with what happened so far
the forces of Westeros formed an
alliance and audits take down the White
Walkers and after defeating the night
king they stormed King's Landing
together besting the bureaucrats and
golden company easily but we weren't
given the happy ending that everyone was
expecting and the bloodlust and power
has sent Danny off the deep end no
matter how many times Tyrion said won't
somebody please think of the children
she still ended up in a rage that
destroyed the majority of the city it
seems like no one not even a petition to
remake this season can stop her and we
head into the final episode wondering
what will happen to the uneasy alliance
between her forces and Jon Snow's
episode six picks up in the aftermath of
the devastation with the opinions of who
was right completely divided those
who've seen my leaked plot video will
know that it was 100% accurate and that
had fans pretty divided so I can imagine
that this will carry over the first half
of the episode culminated in the death
of Daenerys at the hands of Jon Snow and
from the off it was clear this was the
only way that the plot could go we
opened with Tyrion discovering Cersei
and Jaime under the rubble he realizes
this has been caused by his failing to
convince Danny but make no mistake about
it he blames no one else but
it's clear that she's had a huge
influence over gray room - whose squad
can be found murdering Lannister
soldiers under the apparent orders of
the Queen Darth Vader Dani is here and
she announces to the world that the war
is not over until she liberates the rest
of it Dani knows what Tyrion has been up
to as well and after the way she swiftly
dealt with Varys things don't look good
for him
however the hero though he takes off the
hand badge and throws it at her those
who've been here since the stall will
remember that Ned Stark did this ticking
Robert when he wished to kill Daenerys
so it's a great callback the crowd of
unsullied and Dothraki cheer and Tyrion
approaches Daenerys she accuses him of
freeing Jaime and that too sees Tyrion
accosted in a similar way John seems to
be the only one that's still team Danny
but even he's having his doubts he
utters the words love is the death of GE
which is a callback to maester aemon
saying that him in season 1 after the
death of Ned
Tyrion asks John to kill Danny before we
get another Mad King saga and as the
rightful heir he is the only one that
can really do it deep down he knows that
Sansa will never bend the knee and this
is a choice between his real family and
adopted one he goes to the Red Keep and
sees Daenerys guarded by drogon this
entire section is a huge callback to her
vision in season 2 and it's nice that
the writers remember this as it was much
needed jump leads for Tyrians life but
it's clear that she isn't budging and he
says you are my queen now and forever
the two kiss but unfortunately for Dany
it's all a ruse and John has made his
choice he stabs Daenerys killing her in
the process drogon approaches but
instead of burning him he burns only the
throne now this segment was a big point
of contention in my plot League video as
there's no real reason why a dragon
would know the politics enough to do
this it also annoyed people that the
thing that's been sought after for so
long was stripped away and after eight
seasons of guessing who would sit on the
throne nobody did yes I can see how this
could be seen as a bit of a cop-out in
the moment I do think it works and it's
a good send-off for Daenerys yes I said
it right let me rephrase that from the
way the plots been building so far this
is the best
send off we could have got I mean it's
not like Cersei being crushed by rocks
at least this had some real dramatic
weight to it which I do appreciate
just please don't comes down this video
the second part of the episode deals
with the aftermath of her death there's
a gathering of the great Lords with John
pretty much been put on trial for
murdering the Queen Tyrion isn't out of
the woods yet either and whilst normally
these decisions would be at the hands of
the king or queen there currently isn't
one together they decide that bran
should be the one as he's pretty much
the wisest and again this is another
thing that people went wild over in the
spoiler video and I can't really
disagree with them the choice of bran
makes little sense to me and I've had a
week to get used to the idea he's not
really the kind of person who would
quest after power he's sort of above
that whole appointed positions thing so
this doesn't really seem like the
correct narrative choice to make and all
in all it looks like that remake the
eighth season petition is about to get a
lot more signatures
anyway Sansa seems to agree with me too
and while she loves him she doesn't bend
the knee and remains the leader of the
north which will stand independent bran
decides that Tyrion should be his hand
and together they go see John who we
learn is being sent to the wall no one
is happy brian says which is a good
compromise
he's already acting like a politician
from here on out we get a great epilogue
Sansa sits atop the throne re si she's
sailing west of Westeros because no one
has been there Brienne records the deeds
of Jaime
grand maester Samwell has been appointed
and he's written a story of the Great
War named as Song of Fire and Ice this
moment killed me a bit inside right
because last night before the episode of
tweeted that if the season didn't end
with Sam writing a book and looking up
at the camera and saying it truly was a
game of Thrones then we riot so yeah
this was pretty hilarious to me as I
didn't realize how right I was
anyway the finale ends with jianming
tormund at the wall and finally finally
patent ghost the story ends how it began
with the Nights Watch venturing into the
woods the same woods from season 1 and
thus the circle is complete the Night
Watch will forever protect the north and
they finally manage to go
what once more instead of retreating
like we saw in the first season the
world is finally safe and we can
hopefully trust bran to not mess it all
up it truly was a game of Thrones that's
out that's happened in the video anyway
I'm off to go sign some petitions
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the game of Thrones finale and what
you think of season 8 as a whole whether
you hate here or you love it the
controversy surrounding it has been very
interesting so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my entire playlist of
videos on the season so far
this contains all of the plot leaks
predictions and even an 11 minute video
of all of the cast being disappointed
with the outcome of season 8 so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want a bit of fun now that this is all
over we've also just launched a merch
section on the channel so if you want to
support videos like this and get
something back make sure you click the
boxes in the description below it goes a
long way to helping us out and we
massively appreciate it
so thank you this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]